الارهاب الرياضي مصطلح مو غريب على ايران
خاصه لبن نشوف اللي صاروا بيصير في
الرياضه الايرانيه واللي كاس العالم يعني
بيثبتوا اكثر واكثر
الارهاب الرياضي حقيقي وبتمارس السلطات
بحق رياضيين ما لهم علاقه بالسياسه بس مع
ذلك مجادرين طبعا يتخلصون من ارهاب
الحكومه الايرانيه خلال مباراه ايران
الاولى في كاس العالم امتنع لاعبين
المنتخب من اداء النشيد الوطني
الناس انه تضامنا مع الاحتجاجات اللي
بتشهدها ايران من 16 سبتمبر ولكن المشهد
اختلاف في المباراه يوم الجمعه اللاعبين
تمتموا بكلمات النشيد الوطني والناس
استغربت التغيير المفاجاه وردت الفعل على
التغيير المفاجاه هذه كانت حتى اللحظيه
شوهد بكاء علني وعلى الشاشات للناس بين
الجماهير لحظه ترتيب او ترديد المنتخب
التغيير عمل ضجه من الجمهور اللي وصل لحد
بكاء علني وعلى بسبب اداء الفريق للنشيد
الوطني وبين الشعب يبكي داخل وخارج ايران
تبينت الحقيقه سريعها فاتضح انه لاعبي
المنتخب اتعرضوا للتهديد من قبل الدوله من
اللي هيصير فيهم لمن يرجعوا اذا ما
تراجعوا عن موقفهم وغنوا ان شئت فطبعا
اضطروا يغنوا الارهاب الرياضي اللي بيتكلم
عنه مو بشويه التهديد هذا اللي تعرضوا له
اللعيبه علشان يغلوا النشيد الوطني فسلطات
الايرانيه معروفه بعمليات اعدام واعتقال
للرياضيين فسابقا تم اعدام سته رياضيات من
بينهم بطل في المصارعه بسبب اتهامات
بالوقوف ضد النظام الايراني ومن كم يوم تم
اعتقال لاعب كره القدم المدافع فوريا
جفوري واللي هو ايراني كوردي بسبب اتهامه
بالسلوك الموشين ضد وطنه والتحريض على
الدوله
حارس المرمى السابق المعروف بدعمه
للاحتجاجات ومعلن هذا الشيء هو معلن هذا
الشيء على حساباته وهذا اتهم تحديدا
بتدمير ممتلكات عامه اثناء الاحتجاجات
والفكره انا قلت لكم قبل يعني لانه
الارهاب الرياضي ما هو جديد على السلطات
الايرانيه يعني في قصص طلعت من سنه 98
يعني من 24 سنه تقريبا وقت خلال مباريات
او مباراه ايران مع الولايات المتحده في
كاس العالم في فرنسا وبين الشوطين
المسؤولين الايرانيين الصادره جوازات سفر
اللعيبه وقالوا لهم لو ما فزتوا ما في
رجعه على ايران عموما المباراه انتهى بفوز
ايران اثنين واحد وعموما كمان لقاء
المنتخبين هيتجدد بعد بكره في قطر ونشوف
اكثر